now our system doesn't rely on
individual responsibility it relies on
individual interests lots of venture
capitalists and startups and
entrepreneurs and technologists and
university researchers have a lot to
gain by breaking the mold here so to
speak and once you crack the problem
there's economic gain to be had whether
you are a professor at Howard or
entrepreneur in Texas and that's where
the responsibility in some sense lies is
to enable the system of experimentation
and success and failure for these
entrepreneurs big companies will do the
same thing and they should participate
just as much as anybody else but I
suspect they're less prone to innovation
especially in the energy business the
responsibility if there is any lies with
policymakers do make sure the
environment allows these new ideas to
emerge well not everybody is qualified
to but spec but there are lots of people
who can contribute to hourly and
technical breakthroughs I believe today
that is the key to progress and once we
have those breakthroughs then we need to
wrap them with management and have
managed execution talent in those are
all entrepreneurial opportunities pretty
much for anybody who can contribute to
those key skill sets that are required
I believe environmentalist like to talk
about that I don't believe that is the
key to solving this problem clearly it
helps if people are using less fuel
clearly ill it helps if they're using
less energy but I think technical
breakthroughs will be the key to
cracking the oil and coal problems now
we should spend some time on call